philot has today become the 31st member
of NATO
the era of military non-alignment in our
history has come to an end
a new era begins
each country maximizes its own security
so does Finland
NATO membership strengthens our
International position and room for
maneuver
as a partner we have already long
actively participated in NATO activities
as an ally Finland will contribute to
NATO's Collective deterrence and defense
membership of the alliance provides
security for Finland
Finland on the other hand provides
security for the aliens
Finland committed to the security of all
NATO member states will be a reliable
Ally
that strengthens Regional stability
Finance membership is not targeted
against anyone
nor does it change the foundations or
objectives of finland's foreign and
security policy
Finland is a stable and predictable
Nordic country that seeks peaceful
resolution of disputes
the principles and values that are
important to Finland will continue to
guide our foreign policy also in the
future
NATO membership does not change
everything
but being an ally requires Finland to
adopt new ways of thinking and some
changes in legislation as well
a lot has already been done for years we
have developed our NATO compatibility
there's still considerable work ahead to
integrate finland's defense as part of
NATO's common defense
The Finnish Defense Forces are facing
new demands and challenges to which we
must respond
at the same time it is clear that
Finance most significant contribution to
NATO's Collective deterrence and defense
is built on the security and defense of
our own territory
in this respect the fear not Finnish
concept of comprehensive security
retains its value
but we no longer do this work alone
last year Finland applied to join NATO
together with the Sweden
as I have stressed Finance membership is
not complete without that of Sweden
our persistent efforts for a rapid
Swedish membership will continue
I look forward to seeing Sweden join us
as the 32nd member at the bill news
Summit in July
to adopt I want to thank you Mr
Secretary General dear yes and your
people your help has been
very important you have been
packing Us in every moment of this
procedure we really gave a lot of value
to that and to our partners thank you
[Applause]